hello everyone and welcome back to the
Lynn Doris Abby rabbit challenge we are
continuing with the first time a final
match between Hugh Colorado camera and
magnus carlsen Magnus won Game one and
this is now Game two he caught up with
the white pieces he needs a win to get
back into the match but before we check
it out I would just like to make a very
short shout out to to despair here they
sent me this it's a video of them where
he plays a piano while simultaneously
playing against his girlfriend and she's
commentating on their game so it's
really crazy stuff I don't know if
anyone attempted it before but if you're
interested in checking out the entire
video I do recommend it it will be the
first thing you see in the description
below so do check it out and now let us
return to the game now Nakamura with the
white pieces opened with e4 with E 5 by
Magnus Knight f3 knight c6 and now
Bishop to b5 the rule opus is on the
board and now Magnus does go for the
Berlin defense with Knight to f6
probably Nakamura would have gone for it
too if it was played in the previous
game however Magnus surprised him with
the Scorch so the three we have Bishop
to c5 and now a trade here characters
captures and now just Knight B to d2
continuing development we already
mentioned why you do not capture on e5
so Bishop to g4 are developing while
painting the night here and h3 asking do
you want to capture or go back so Bishop
to h5 and now there are a couple of
moves that have been played here but the
MU Nakamura plays a3 is a new move so
already as of mu 8 we have a completely
new game
Magnus continues with Knight to d7 now
you want to further defend this pawn you
want to play f6 you want to bring your
King to safety and just keep the
position very solid now camera goes g4
advances the pawn on the King side
Bishop to g6 and also be 4 so not a lot
of time will you see something like this
a 3 a 3 B 4 followed by h3g 4 so pushing
the bishop back with Bishop to d6 and
now Knight to c4 putting pressure on the
bishop but but actually the knight is
just coming to a5 to put pressure on b7
and c6 so f6 by Maggie
standard move in the Berlin and Knight
to a5 now putting pressure on b7 and not
allowing b6 since then you lose the c6
pawn so Magnus defends it we have Queen
to c8 and not Knight the h4 again
putting pressure on the bishop but this
Knight is actually just coming to f5
which will be an excellent outpost for
the night so we have a knight the f8 the
defending the bishop if the bishop is
captured in the knight can recapture on
g6 also then the knight will have access
to the f4 square but nakamora just to
shift the night over to f5 and if you
trade here then nakamura gets a nice
semi open file for his rook so nice the
e6 Magnus now also has eyes on d4 an f4
which will be some good squares for his
Knight and Bishop the e4 developing and
also helping a with control of those
squares with King to f7 Magnus now wants
to cast artificially by shifting the
rook into the game and playing King g8 +
c3 now now putting adding another
defender to before but also taking
taking away the d4 square from Carlson's
night we have looked the EA to now
almost finished casting artificially and
not h4 by Nakamura preparing h5 to force
a trade here so King to g8 freeing up
the f7 square for the bishop and now h5
attacking that Bishop with Bishop to f7
and now Queen to f3 are getting the
Queen enter game and here Magnus finds a
very nice move that allows him to to
gain some activity with b6 and here
Magnus is just offering the c6 pawn so
if you capture it problem is if you
capture it in Queen d7 you have to play
b5 and it's a very committal move and
Nakamura isn't isn't sure if he wants to
commit all the way could be a weak pawn
after a 6 it's hard to decide if this is
good or bad
so instead Nakamura goes back with the
Knight to c4 he doesn't go go for the c6
pawn and now Bishop back to f8 not
allowing the capture to happen on d6 and
also the Bishop from f8 will serve as a
nice defender of the Kings side so
Nakamura castles here and now a5 now
finally getting that breakthrough as the
knight is no longer blocking blacks a
pawn
we have Queens the g3 by Nakamura
putting a lot of pressure here on
Carlson's Queen side sir King side and
you have to take a lot of things into
consideration maybe some sacrifices are
possible with the night maybe with the
bishop maybe h6 so a lot of things to
consider but Magnus just goes a capture
Sun before first we have a see capture
some before and now h6 not allowing you
Nakamura to push to push the H or the G
pawn and now rook F to D 1 preparing to
bust open the position with the d4 as
you really want to get rid of this
backwards d3 pawn so Magnus first goes
b5 kicks away the knight Knight 2 d2 and
then now c5 so just advancing that phone
Magnus also gets rid of his paddle C
pawn be captures and now we have bishop
characters on c5 by Magnus we have
captures captures now putting pressure
on the d3 pawn and here nakamura should
go d4 right away it's an excellent
opportunity d4 pawn is defended by the
night so you just need to get rid of
your backwards d3 pawn however nakamura
goes Knight to f3 first and now it's a
bit of a problem now cross and gets
Queen to d7 in and now you no longer
have d4 as nothing will guard your e4
pawn so now you have to decide whether
you want to defend it with Knight to the
e1 now okay the the d3 point will be
defend the three times or you want to do
it like Nakamura with King to h2 which
defends the d3 pawn would a tactic now
if Magnus captures if now 91 just picks
up the night since it's now attacked
three times so instead after King to h2
we have Bishop to e6 and and now
Nakamura has to figure out how to how to
continue this game he goes for rook 8 2
c1 brings the rook to a more active file
now attacks the night here on c5 but now
Magnus just goes Knight to b3 puts
pressure on the rook but what he's
actually doing is preventing the rook
from reaching the a1 square and now a
Nakamura loses the a3 pawn so rook the
c3 and rook captures on a3 now by Magnus
and the situation on the clock is two
and a half minutes Nakamura four minutes
for Magnus Nakamura now finally gets his
d4 move in d5 would be excellent if he
can get that in however here
Magnus has a few very good options he
couldn't go c 5 c 5 is interesting since
you can't really do any captures the
rook would be hanging here and after d 5
you can just capture here and after
whichever pawn recaptures now you have
before and now you have to connect at
past points here which will be very
strong
so after D for Magnus decides not to go
for c5 but rather b5 first and now
already that's a very strong past point
you're challenging the rook and also
after the rook moves you just want to
capture this point since the pawn will
now be guarding the rook here on a3 so
rook c d3 and the knight captures on d4
a very nice idea now nakamura characters
and i three characters on d4e captures
on d4 and you cannot go for captures
with the rook because the Queen would
hang on g3 so here what you do is eat a
capture by the knight but if you capture
with the knight then you just get rook
capture Sangeeth on the three Queen
captures and Bishop captures energy for
puts pressure on the rook here and it's
just much better it is winning for black
as the two connected past points would
be unstoppable so here after Bishop
captures sorry after ECAP person d4 we
have rook captures an 83 by nakamura B
captures on a3 and now only now real
character Sundy for attacking Carlson's
Queen and Carlsen finds the very
interesting Queen to b5 which is pretty
much the only move that gives the black
the advantage he offers both the C pawn
and the a3 pawn
however capturing either isn't all that
great because if you capture the a3 pawn
then you just get Bishop captures and f5
and the white cannot recapture the
bishop because if you recapture then
Queen to e5 Czech picks up the rope here
on d4 so that would be a problem so
instead nakamura grabs the c7 pawn at
least now he will only have the a3 pond
to worry about and now Magnus goes in
for the kill so what would you play here
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the best move for Magnus well I'll
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations
unsporting that it is it is very very
important to eliminate the night and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy the
show it's a bishop captures on f5 and
now it doesn't matter what nakamura
recaptures with he captures and fi was
played and now just queen-to-be to and
now there is a very little Nakamura can
do against a 2 and a 1 this point is
becoming a queen you don't you don't
have time for something like rook to d7
to go after g7 phone because the f2
point is hanging as well so that's not
possible you were gonna get mated so
here Nakamura finds a very interesting
tactic on how to defend the Queen to c4
check King to h8 and now King the g3
defending the f2 pawn but now Magnus
does get a 2 in but this was Nakamura's
idea Queen to a4 and now of course if
you continue by promoting the pawn which
I hope none of you were considering you
get just rook Queen captures rook any 8
check King here check here and rook to
d8 will be checkmate so Magnus doesn't
fall for this of course he goes for
Queen to d8 with just go goes back Queen
to b8 and now the problem is you don't
really have much options here it comes
with checks so you first have to react
to this but it was also in this position
that he called Nakamura resigned the
game what if you resigned well there is
nothing more to be done here since once
you deal with this let's say you move
the King King h3 just Queen e8 and next
move either either the Queen moves and
then you bring another Queen enter game
or you trade here and still the pond
will Queen there's no way for you to
stop this so while the really wild stuff
and the really impressive how Magnus got
all of this going at this point this was
the crucial idea let me just let me just
find it here nope and that's not where
the crucial idea was here just this very
interesting b6 move just a beautiful
pawn sacrifice that allowed he karu the
to be bold and go after the c6 pawn now
but he car went back and then it was
just a very very simple development
for Magnus sure it was this this at this
point that things started to go wrong
for Hikaru but that's that's how it is
interests you have to make a decision if
you make make a wrong decision then it
it will of course an opponent like
magnets will take advantage of this so
once again that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it do check out the video I
mentioned that the link or the link is
in the description below the first thing
you will see first time I've seen
someone simultaneously play the piano
and play a chess game so do check it out
and also I would like to thank Mark
Thompson Christopher Oliver Sean Owen a
Mark Baum parent and I found Francois
bond for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I'm thinking for watching
and I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Lin Doris a be rapid
challenge checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day